We invite you to continue
to join some worship up through baptism.
Good morning Church. This is Josiah.
He is an eighth grader in the student ministry.
And this past summer at student camp, uh,
under the leadership of Brent Reynolds, Cole Bone
and Logan Armstrong, Josiah started asking questions about
what it means to be a Christian.
Uh, fast forward to September, on a Wednesday night,
we're having conversations about what that means.
And, uh, every Wednesday night
for about a month, we keep talking.
And then in October, during our night of worship,
after that, he, uh, gave his life to Christ.
Uh, he, yeah. Praise God. Yeah.
Yes, Josiah, uh, the Lord has been drawing Josiah closer
to him, uh, over the past few months.
And, uh, he is ready to, uh, sit before you
and make this profession of faith.
So Josiah, based on our conversations
and what the Lord has been doing, it is my privilege
to baptize you In name of the Father, son, and Holy Spirit.
Yeah. Let's, uh, let's pray for Josiah.
God, thank you for just this church family who, uh,
rallies around and celebrates you working.
Lord, thank you for the work that you have done
and will continue to do in Josiah's life.
Lord, I pray that we would be encouraged by
who you are and God, how you save broken,
lost, confused, hurting people.
Lord, would you, uh, not only work in his life,
but in all of our lives, would you continue to make us
more like Jesus today?
In your name we pray, amen. Amen. Church, we are sent.